a Seattle restaurant asked a patron to
leave after he was wearing Google glass
in the restaurant the guy went on a rant
on facebook and the restaurant owners
they didn't take it lying down they
posted this on Facebook if you do wear
Google glasses inside or film or
photograph people without their
permission you will be asked to stop or
leave and if we ask you to leave for
God's sakes don't start yelling about
your rights just shut up and get out
before you make things worse that's
David minor who is the restaurant owner
up in Seattle I really love that because
yes that's the point you know
everybody's going to be doing this and
then everyone's gonna be screaming about
their rights and it's my google glass
but yeah just leave or shut them off or
take them off I think this google glass
is really going to fundamentally change
how humans interact uh should we be
expecting this all time if you got to
restaurant are you gonna mind being
recorded at all times by sure you can't
mine because uh I know my sneaky as
friends we you know you pretend you're
taking a selfie and all of a sudden it's
like but that guy I know him from
something okay see so people are already
being recorded against their will but I
love that this is really the only part
of the country this could happen in
where else besides near Silicon Valley
or you've just too much of a google
glass problem have you ever actually
seen anyone wear Google I haven't yet
but when it's starting there but you
know this is coming across I mean I once
this thing gets cheaper it's not even
fully out yet I think it's still in beta
testing or whatever do you fear that
we're gonna be living in this constant
recorded digital I think history and the
the way I'm ridiculed at the Young Turks
everyday knows that you know I think
everyone's suspicious so if I see anyone
if I see google glass I may be the one
that goes to restaurant managers and the
gavotte it's a looks a little suspicious
and if you don't take care of it I'm
gonna take care of it yeah so then it
all gets its days you know the guy over
there eating a salad but I'm gonna take
care of it would you get the crap out of
it what do you say listen um I don't you
know you need to confront people who you
think are up to no good I'm sorry and if
they're not cool if it's again is the
second time I'm gonna sound like
Republican in this in this particular
show
if you're not doing anything take them
off right right what they would argue
but they would argue that the heart of
what the owner of the restaurant was
saying is that it's their right it's
their right to use their body and the
electronic equipment attached to their
body I mean soon it's going to be built
into us right right isn't it's just so
refreshing to on the flip side to hear a
restaurant manager not customer always
right yourself if you later if we don't
want you here get out yeah like how
great of that I want to eat there yeah
serve the right to refuse service to
anyone new shirt no shoes recording
glasses that you know look through your
shirt and post online no survey yeah I
think you're onto something with this
idea that we're all going to be
constantly watching each other and and
doing surveillance on each other it's
bad enough the government's doing us but
it reminds me a little bit of the movie
and the book scanner darkly by philip k
dick about how we all will become these
things that are constantly reporting on
each other because they'll be able to
hack into your google glasses and then
watch what you're watching when you
don't even know we talked about nineteen
eighty-four with surveillance you know
what when other citizens are surveilling
others that's 1985 they never wrote does
this all lead us to ultimately living in
like a matrix style digital world you
know the whole point I think of the
matrix was that our bodies are just
going to become sort of batteries for
this digital world that will really live
in and we'll need some food to keep
alive but everything else is going to
exist in that and maybe we just have to
figure out why we're so obsessed with it
why is it so interesting to us because
maybe when we figure it out and we
realize it's not as interesting as we
thought it was we'll go back to just
having a conversation I'm as guilty if
not more than anywhere else I get
every day for the amount of selfies and
pictures and sunsets and all the
that nobody wants to look at me
I put them up more than anybody so I
guess we all have to figure out why why
do we do it what why are we why are we
allowing ourselves to do it and what's
the desire behind it yeah well it's to
mystify it's to interact with people
even when you're not sure if they want
to interact with you so we have this
obsession want to do it so okay once we
run out of the first wave of using our
phones in our google glass for the first
purposes then you start going
well that's gonna do with this exam it
goes it goes deviance so then so
speaking of that he be a part of it
should we have any reasonable
expectation of privacy if you walk down
the street right now you could be you
know photographed by google the earth
the earth or the car thing that's
driving by and mapping everything but we
don't expect it to be coming from other
people so should we have any reasonable
expectation you do you have any right to
not be photographed or we already know
that if you're famous you don't have a
right because there's people hiding in
the bushes with telephoto lens taking
your picture and we're totally fine with
that if you make a certain amount of
money and have an expected certain
amount of awesome life then you've given
up all your privacy so I guess we're
just the next tier couple tears down
right so is this who was it everyone's
gonna have their 15 minutes of fame who
said that way yes this the Andy Warhol
thing maybe he really was but fifteen
minutes of fame against their will you
didn't ask or I got to combat it with
the other house is being born we're big
dumpy sweat pants and walk around and do
nothing fun and no no pic take pictures
of you no one will pay attention to you
that's I went out I went to trader joe's
in sweatpants last week and I felt very
piece of garbage yeah I felt like George
in Seinfeld remember he's wearing
sweatpants Jerry's like you've
officially given up yes la residents
left the story were telling you like I
went to the store but pants I looked at
that badly the mouse
you